an intense person and so I've had  intense relationships prior you know so  and that's based on how you make them  feel like you've described as well but  also if they're a little bit crazy like  but in  intense relationships and toxic  relationships they're lit but obviously  they're not sustained they're not  sustainable yeah they're unsustainable I  mean like when you wake up and there's  like someone standing over with a knife  you just I go aggravated  has that happened to you yeah yeah but  it was a different girl who tried to  push me downstairs yes  yeah but I'm like you're like five foot  you need to check yeah  this is crazy yeah